welcome to new game against hmm low cam
lo Clem from Australia right yeah
Australia and ce4 let's see an English
opening the many transpositions okay we
stay within the English opening
territory c6 is a quite an interesting
line chat some fairly solid choice okay
it seems he wants to play with g6 this
is in fact quite similar to UM to an
ideas of the bogo in Dominion you try to
get rid of your dark squared bishop and
then set your pawns on dark squares yeah
i just remembered the ideas with the
quick d5 here maybe like there should be
six and then d5 ok he wants to go with B
5
okay I don't mind that too much I can
always go d 5v5 d5 and it this should um
should be a little something with the
space advantage
where's the bishop going actually to 2g
for no no this is an interesting
question i would like to to put a pawn
on before before to fix it on light
squares here on b5 but before he's got a
five and i don't have time for a three
maybe I should prepared III then before
like he could yeah to do that and now
i'm preparing before yeah i thought this
was simply impossible but he played it
anyway and quickly as usual because of
night a to winning the before porn maybe
i'm overlooking something tactic maybe
we should be five something like that
yeah it's a bit bit on ammonius but you
just played before without any
particular idea if you get some
compensation it's just coincidental okay
i could I should take em no big no big
alternative him
no yeah now he's got some compensation I
go nite see to for example take stakes
is godrick a 2 at the end and that is
some compensation okay but what does he
really threatening not yeah maybe we
should be too
hmm takes can can take with the king
it's not it's not terrible
yeah not easy to coordinate though maybe
I need to prepare this with Roxy 192 I
mean so that after all those captures
the night is protected not easy but he
does not have such a great follow-up
move here I think you have this but this
allows knight c6 I can take ok too ok so
we has a good follower move exactly that
one goodnight c5 coming I should have
played f3 as I wanted originally
I can just take t3 he can just take
these three I know I need to break him I
need a break I mean it is just
blundering upon and it sits for no
particular reason leading to great
compensation if this stuff is going to
happen in usually should take a break
and now why not Queen a 6 or whatever
what is he doing you can just keep the
peace Queen a 6 Queen B 5 it's all
winning and easily
Queen a six or this one it's down is
there some some trick some reason why is
spending all this time this one maybe
maybe this irritated him I can go to a
six down again my rook c6 yeah but
that's not really working this nice
Knight b6 the only reason I'm not
resigning is because he is spending so
much time girl Alfred game drawn what
what you can just go to a six and I'm
resigning I don't understand what's
going on what even here you can take
afore I mean I was just blundering this
yeah the thing is this is this is after
this I'm already in trouble ninety-seven
SOS winning for black the computer gives
black and win already I'm so much tied
up Wow amazing and this is always always
funny because when you dash this out in
a second he was never considering well
this is a great porn sec because
something it just happens by coincidence
and then during it and you don't have
the good move I was originally thinking
this one but look at this yeah yeah even
this this kind of stuff it's I mean he
has something rook c8 and I don't know
maybe this is see a computer likes white
but I didn't I didn't
our computer wants to play this move and
black has a great compensation again
amazing yeah this is lost really 95 is
so strong I have no I cannot castle I
have no move I mean this is terrible
because it's very easy but i have no
more in this position amazing yeah then
then this also means that my idea here
was was not good maybe i need to refine
that well one in general to play for
this move is a good idea but they'll
probably need to do this then but ok can
play 9 a-6 for example yeah it's it's
probably about equal nothing ok I can't
play before hmm yeah still black should
be ok Queen B 6 and so on so it's okay I
didn't play that good didn't play that
well at all and the weirdest thing is
that achieve that day that that already
got to the strange kind of drop ok
thanks for watching